地ツアー
大きなクマのぬいぐるみ良かったんですけども
今したの玄関の方に引っかかってるねー
とりあえず巨大なぁクマのぬいぐるみをここまで持っていきます
もうその像ですただ本当にちょっと出稼ぎ引っかかって動けねえんだよ
おおいうん
[音楽]
ん
だめだ完全に引っかかったやれん
すごい4カ所大丈夫かうん
tak rem
あのですねなんかこういう大きなクマのぬいぐるみはコストコとかで買える力をする
くっんですけど僕は発足行員がコスト部会員ではないしてこそ特にいったこともあり
ますよいケアでもなんたらって言ってるんですけどそこでもないでスコットも前売り系
って聞いたんですけども
俺はそういうなんかカンインとかめんどくさいがあまりしない人です静岡の近く
の温泉にこの日組が置いてあって全部停車に聞いたら買えますよって言われてその後
温泉で買いました
で買ったんですけどもう音声で見たやつ全然大きい
玄関の通らないんですよプレイですねこいつ
こっちの版もう2回に運びます今日はこいつは運び出すだけの動画だからね
よし
問題はどうやった昆布であるんだよどうすればいいわけ
ん
ここでも引っ掛かっちゃうんですよ
んん
ピンクさあどうすよめっちゃ美味しかった
運べないんだけど横に横にしてみようかな
横澤いきそうだねうん
ん
まず膝有効なの犬引っ張って
これと会で入るんじゃねぇ普通にトイレに入るトイレにはクマは入れそうです
引き続き上の部屋まで持っていきます
思うん
ちょっと待って来いつくれぽじとレースも損ですよ
siro プロだしていこう
うそ私がここはですねこりゃオレはーやー
うーん
おん
うわぁ
押し
うんん
さあん
うわぁ
帰れさここまでこれはもう言ってるでしょ
よしよしよし
またここに立たせるだけだ
よしどうだ
うそーずっと hands up 自立できないの kimi
ねぇまぁ
終わっ誉さーん
悪いつ立たないんですけど死んでる寂しい c ほかよく東京都が行くのでペットも
飼えないのでちょっと寂しいですよ
寂しさを紛らわすために工場女性がねこちらのところ座を買ったわけですよ
ジャイ子ねーよたしか座ってる時はさっかー160センチぐらいです
ポツと
はもう2メートルを超える心情とかあるいは2つどうも2メートルを超えるらしいん
ですけども足は冬なんでも意味ないですよ
あっ育った amazon で売ってるの見ました the metal 普通に火を
止めも買えると思います
これねーこれいいわっはっはーちょっと寂しい進化だったんですけどもやっと根っこを
ちょっとオリジナリティやってたと思います来なかったらさ
[音楽]
par ん
ハーン
e 4 e 種
ten